[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka leak skywalker
and with just two episodes left of the
mandalorian i thought i'd break down the
best fan theories that are floating
around in a galaxy far
far away in the latest episode we
watched boba fett return
moth gideon take grogu and mando put the
pieces in place to save his surrogate
son from the clutches of the empire
judging by the end of episode 6 we can
pretty much guess that the next entry
will be a prison break to bust bilber
out
and that nick frost will probably pop up
along the way
however i want to look beyond that and
search my feelings to discuss what i
think could happen in the finale
as well as some of the best fan theories
that i've come across before we get into
that though
just a reminder that we do videos like
this each and every day
so if you're new to the channel then
please subscribe if you're excited for
the finale then make sure you stay
locked
as we'll be doing an in-depth breakdown
right after it drops on disney plus
anyway the first thing that we need to
discuss is what exactly is going to
happen demando
now that he no longer has the razor
crest whilst he's currently making his
way through the galaxy in the cockpit of
slave one with boba fett and fennec
shand
there will come a point where he has to
find his own vehicle
now i actually think that the show might
kill fete off and have
mando inherit slave one from him as
discussed in the last episode
fete's father was a fouling as well and
as both mando and grogo are too
they do share some sort of kinship even
though they aren't related
tamira morrison is also getting a bit
you know a bit and though i don't want
to call him bobber fat
it's unlikely that he can keep appearing
as the character for years and years and
years
thus i think his death and handing over
the ship could be somewhat of a passing
of the torch
both literally in the show and
figuratively as the fans favorite bounty
hunter
we would very much get the idea of the
old passing things off to the new
and it would mean that mando could carry
across the iconography of fett
while still doing his own thing let's be
honest when the mandalorian was first
announced
many people thought that it was going to
be the story of young boba fett
so this does line up with something that
people want to see
now eckhart's ladder actually posted a
pic of what they think mano's next ship
will be
and in case you don't know this actually
comes from the expanded law
and is the one that feck got after
escaping the sarlacc
if that cannon is carried across to this
continuity then vet would have both and
potentially
mando could be given that one as fat
will no longer have any use for it
now as for grogu the fact that we know
the next episode will be a prison break
means they probably won't have the time
to also go and rescue him
therefore the little lad is going to be
spending a lot of time with the empire
and moff gideon gideon was already
throwing stormtroopers his way
and grogu had no problem throwing them
back so i think that by the time we get
back to the character
he may be leaning more towards the dark
side ahsoka did warn mando that it was
dangerous to train him because of their
attachment
and that if they were separated it could
lead to him going down a dark path she
has of course seen this in regards to
anakin
and though his mother died which meant
there was no coming back
mando is still alive actually think that
when we see grogu it will be a big shock
to see how much he has changed in such a
short time
because of gideon's influence children
often suck up everything around them
like a sponge
and it's often adults who shape their
personalities so if he has moff gideon
as a moth guardian then he's probably
not gonna be the snack snatching fella
that we've come to love you're dead you
mate you're bloody dead
now what this leads to is what's gonna
happen when the pair inevitably becomes
separated down the line
mando's entire quest seems to be to
reunite the character with a jedi
so that he can start his training
however i don't actually think that this
will be the case
and instead i think the jedi will give
mando some basic inklings on what to do
and that the character will actually
take it upon himself to discipline groku
he's clearly open to helping his
abilities and whilst
all we've seen him do is move the silver
ball back and forth
mando could easily help him build up to
bigger things like ships and more
so i do think there's definitely an
opportunity to do something big with the
character
and end the series on a cliffhanger that
makes us wonder whether he can be saved
or not
now mando will of course be pulling him
back but there's also the potential that
he'll have help from another character
that we haven't seen yet grogu has
called out to a jedi
and someone somewhere in the galaxy
probably heard him i'm guessing
so we will likely be seeing a jedi pop
up to perhaps help guide him back from
the darkness
now who this could be is really up in
the air at the moment and a lot of
people think that it may be luke
skywalker
during the time period that the series
is set the character was actually just
about to establish his own jedi academy
and thus grogu is at the perfect point
to be there when it begins
however i don't think that it will be
luke for a number of reasons
which i'll talk about right now
now grogu has already survived one jedi
purge and because of this he had to go
into hiding
we know from the sequel trilogy that ben
solo became kylo ren at one point during
his training
and that he and his knights ransacked
the area before turning to the dark side
therefore i just can't see them being
like well he survived anakin turning
into darth vader and killing everyone
so now we're gonna have him go to a
location where ben solo turns into kylo
ren
and kills absolutely everybody it just
doesn't seem likely to me
there's also a number of logistical
problems with luke and mark hamill
in order to accomplish the character
being the right age
disney would have to do a lot of the
aging and do a couple of nip tucks here
and there
to make sure that the actor is in the
same shape now a couple of people have
said well
they did it in the rise of skywalker and
with sam jackson and captain marvel
which i get yeah but the rise of
skywalker was about three seconds
shot in a pretty dimly lit environment
with little movement in the face
samuel l jackson is also a vampire and
even now
he looks like he's barely aged so
personally i can't see it
i would of course be happy to be proven
wrong but i think the cost of it would
be massive
and disney could quite easily just get
any other jedi in
drop them in the series and and i'm sure
interest amongst the fans
is still gonna be there you also don't
open yourself up to anything like
justice league where the people doing
the cgi
fumbled the project a bit and led to a
complete monstrosity
look i know it wasn't your fault mate
you did the best with the time you had
but you know effects on the face it just
sometimes it doesn't work
now saying that i think it could
definitely be calcus
from fallen order the ball that grogu
sits on is very similar to the ones that
you had to move around in that game
and also the text that we saw on it
appeared throughout the title
kyle used to sit down to meditate and
this allowed you to upgrade your
abilities
and it was also similar to what we see
groggo doing
the character could have potentially
been doing this when groga reached out
and thus
they may have a connection cameron
monahan is of course
already an established actor so it
wouldn't take too much to just move him
across
the only issue is that the game series
obviously wants to continue doing its
own thing
and it might be difficult for them to
tie in with the property while still
carrying on their own continuity there
is however another possibility
and looks like we already have hints
that they could be featuring in the show
that person is ezra bridger though osaka
said she was looking for admiral thrawn
if you're a fan of rebels and you'll
likely know that she is also after ezra
and therefore it makes sense to have him
pop up at some point
rahu kohli actually seems like he may be
cast as the character
as all the way back in september he
dropped a tweet hinting at him getting
into shape
to to basically play ezra star wars
theory also dropped a video the other
day
that seemed a hint towards it hey
uh i was just walking around and i i
think i bumped into
ezra
oh oh oh oh see you later mate hey see
man
i probably should have reached out to
that guy before making this video but i
he's a busy man but all this stuff means
that there's a lot of hype behind not
only the character of ezra
but also rahul to play him the actor
recently told inverse that he'd spent
more time in his garden twirling a
lightsaber
then he had acting and it just makes
perfect sense
the show is clearly going down the clone
wars in rebels root with bo guitar and
ahsoka popping up
so i think if we do get a jedi dropping
in it will most likely be him
or you know we could get that rumored
mace windu spin-off which
i think would absolutely break the
internet or or we could get sebastian
stan
as luke skywalker which yeah would be
a great thing to happen but i i just
don't know how realistic that is
anyway those are the main theories and i
do think that mando will beat them off
using the staff whilst he fights back
with the darksaber
as we know this spear is capable of
blocking it and they just drew
so much attention to it in the last two
episodes that they're clearly pointing
out it's going to be important
it's one of the only weapons that can
stop the darksaber so it makes the most
sense to me
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories so comment below
and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our full breakdown of the latest
episode which is going to be linked at
the end
we go over all the ins and outs of the
entry so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set and all you have to do to begin with
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of december so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavyspoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
bye